it's um it's Controlled Chaos in here
actually it's not controlled at all it
is pure chaos but we love this awesome
we were talking this morning
entertainment for a good cause Jordan
Studios putting on a production of The
Nutcracker with a Latin twist at the
West Las Vegas Library this weekend
um and the reason the dogs are here is
because a portion of that performance is
going to benefit ccsb police's canine
unit who are all here along the stage so
first uh we've got Jimmy Jordan joining
us from the studios and Lieutenant Brian
Singh thank you so much from CCSD police
you guys have partnered up to create
this really incredible relationship
that's what I was thinking
let's talk about the show first because
people at home are going to want to go
see The Nutcracker with the Latin twist
when is it where is it and how can we
get involved yeah so when we open the
studio five years ago we actually wanted
to have a really rigorous ballet program
but also have a place where the kids can
express themselves and kind of dance
improv and things like that and we think
Latin dance is a really great way to do
that yes so when we started doing the
production we took the classical
Nutcracker ballet and we put a little
bit of Latin elements into it like salsa
and Cha-Cha okay yeah and uh tickets are
on sale for 35 you can get them at
Jordan Studios and it's on this Saturday
and this Sunday at six o'clock wonderful
okay so you want to go check out the
performance and and coming up by the way
we are actually going to have them
perform in the studio for us uh the the
performance right now though coming from
the dogs
so let's talk about the partnership here
and CCSD police the canine unit so
important so important to our schools
what do these dogs do for our students
well absolutely so the dogs we have here
today too are firearm detection and then
Oreo here is a drug detection dog but
more importantly it we just think it's a
fantastic partnership with the dance
studio because many of the students are
CCSD students so they're helping their
Community by putting on this production
and the proceeds the portion of the
proceeds that come to us help fund our
canine programs gonna buy food pay for
vet bills the chew toys that the dogs
use is uh as rewards so it's just it's a
fantastic partnership and we're very
excited to get to do this for a second
year in a row and really quick now you
mentioned Oreo and and his Handler is
this is Officer cook okay well cookie
I've made already says and then who do
we have here we have diamond and officer
Woodland and then we have King and
officer Joe Thompson aha all right well
King has been very chatty this morning
wonderful to have them here on the set
we know how hard these dogs work for our
for our kids for our students and the
partnership is so fun between the dance
studio and you guys this is fun for you
too absolutely yeah we do it's a great
time for us to get out and see the team
together and then of course have the
dogs entertain us and they are pure
energy at the show right I don't know
maybe yeah the show you mentioned it is
on the weekend it is The Nutcracker
something that you know we all see it's
just a very classic performance but
you're adding in these Latin Elements
which we're going to see here in just a
little bit okay so gentlemen thank all
of you gentlemen and uh beautiful pups
thank you for getting up early and being
on the show this morning uh Folks at
home stick around because about 6 30
we're gonna have that sneak peek
performance